[Musik]
ein sonniger Tennisplatz in Kemer an der
türkischen Riviera Katharina und
Victoria trainieren ihre Vorhand die
eine ist neun und Ukrainerin die andere
elf und Russin
Wladimir der Trainer ist belarusse
dem Krieg der Nachbarn in der Ukraine
kann Wladimir nichts abgewinnen aber vor
unserer Kamera bleibt der dennoch lieber
vorsichtig
ich bin entschieden gegen alles was da
gerade geschieht
deshalb bin ich weg ich will mich aber
weder für die eine noch für die andere
Seite aussprechen
das ist einfach nicht mein Ding ist
nicht mein Karma
die Realität zu Hause so gut verdrängen
wie es eben geht sein Rezept für die
Kinder am Netz nicht ganz so einfach die
Russin kehrt mit ihren Eltern nach drei
Wochen Trainingscamp zurück nach Moskau
fast wie immer die Ukrainerin ist mit
vier Geschwistern und ihren Eltern erst
einmal hier in Antalya gestrandet ihre
Zukunft ungewiss
Vladimir und seine Frau Olga fühlen sich
wohl hier sie waren selbst lange
Tennisprofis Vladimir auch Trainer des
weißrussischen Damen Teams sie sind weit
gereist haben in New York und Florida
gewohnt vor zwei Monaten dann in Kiel
mehr ihre eigene tennis-akademie
eröffnet die Kunden meist gut
verdienende Nachwuchsspielerinnen und
Spieler aus Russland und Belarus
Anteil ideal
wir fühlen uns fast wie zu Hause an
jeder Ecke wird hier russisch gesprochen
und alles wird in Russisch Angeboten
Kindergarten Schule Schönheitssalon
Restaurants alles
mit Geld lässt sich hier vieles Regeln
sagt Olga ihre Wohnung zahlen die
tennis-unternehmer 3.500 Dollar
monatlich das Siebenfache eines
türkischen Durchschnittsgehalts
von now ist station is like also das
läuft jetzt zu hier die Hausbesitzer
wollen die Miete für ein Jahr im Voraus
Bar plus zwei Monatsmieten Kaution und
die Maklergebühr
and one payment Commission Agent der
Makler hat uns gesagt dass türkische
Bürger jetzt große Probleme hätten
solche mieten könnten die nicht zahlen
Vermieter suchen gezielt ausländische
Mieter weil das satte die Wiesen bringt
die wollen natürlich Euro oder Dollar
keine türkischen Lira
Antalya ist zum Sehnsuchtsort für Russen
geworden vor allem für Russen die über
ausreichend Finanzmittel verfügen die
Türkei erlaubt Ihnen eine Einreise ohne
wiesung seit Anfang des Jahres landeten
zweieinhalb Millionen russische Besucher
hier viele suchen jetzt Wohnungen für
ein ganzes Jahr oder kaufen gleich ein
Haus die Aufenthaltsgenehmigung ist dann
nur noch eine Formalität
einer der beliebtesten Bezirke ist Konya
alte direkt am Strand
[Musik]
Bezirksbürgermeister Bölük berichtet von
dramatischen Veränderungen durch die
Flut russischer Neuankömmlinge die
Behörden mussten jetzt die Notbremse
ziehen
Anzeige Geschichte das Migrationsamt von
Antalya hat für zehn Stadtbezirke einen
Ausländer Stoppel wirkt in meinem Bezirk
Konja alte betrifft das drei Wohnviertel
da kann sich kein Ausländer mehr
niederlassen und anmelden
die Mieten sind einfach horrent
gestiegen dieser neue zuzugstopp wird
hoffentlich dazu führen dass sie nicht
noch weiter steigen
ein herer Wunsch die Realität in Antalya
das weiß yunus Emre sieht ganz anders
aus der 26-Jährige ist Lehrer er hat am
eigenen Leib erfahren wie
Normalverdiener an den Rand gedrängt
werden seine Vermieterin wollte statt
1700 Lira plötzlich 9000 Lehrer Miete
umgerechnet fast 500 statt 90 Euro das
Fünffache so viel wie er im Monat
verdient Junis musste ausziehen jetzt
ist der provisorisch bei Freunden
untergekommen und sucht nach einer
Wohnung die er noch bezahlen kann
ich musste immer so etwa zehn Prozent
vom Gehalt für die Miete ausgeben das
ist vorbei jetzt sind es mindestens 50
bis 60 Prozent
falls ich überhaupt noch was finde
die Mieten sind für Geringverdiener aber
auch für die Mittelschicht eigentlich
nicht mehr bezahlbar und es sieht nicht
so aus als ob das besser werden würde
er hätte seiner Vermieterin verklagen
können der Staat hat Mieterhöhungen auf
maximal 25% begrenzt aber ein Gang durch
die Gerichtsinstanzen das dauert in der
Türkei auf die Jahre mit unsicherem
Ausgang und es kostet Geld das Jonas
nicht hat die Entwicklung verstärkt sagt
er bei vielen Türken noch die Abneigung
gegen Ausländer
Antalya war immer eine Touristenhochburg
an Touristen im Stadtbild hat man sich
natürlich gewöhnt
aber was in den letzten Monaten hier
abgeht ist schon extrem man fühlt sich
im eigenen Land wie ein Ausländer
egal wo wir hingehen selbst wenn man
sich abends mal mit seinen Freunden
trifft es ist alles voll mit Ausländern
der Preisdruck den die russischen
Zuwanderer im Wohnungsmarkt erzeugen
trifft eine türkische Bevölkerung die
ohnehin unter dramatischem
währungsverfall und einer Inflation von
85% leidet der Mindestlohn wurde schon
dreimal angehoben er liegt mit
umgerechnet 300 Euro aber immer noch
unterhalb der vom türkischen
Gewerkschaftsverband errechneten
Armutsgrenze
die Situation das weiß der Leiter der
Verbraucherzentrale Antalya zu berichten
ist auf dem wohnungsmarktkatastrophal
wer eine Immobilie besitzt der macht
gerade Kasse die meisten an der Steuer
vorbei Kontrollen gibt es so gut wie
keine
wir haben jede Menge mieterbeschwerden
hier bei der Beratung
die Vermieter zwingen auch langjährige
Mieter die Wohnung zu räumen
die Mieter werden unter Druck gesetzt
teilweise bedroht
wir sind klar der Vermieter sieht dass
die Ausländer exorbitante Mieten zahlen
und will dann natürlich seinen Teil vom
Kuchen
Sorgen über hoher mieten muss sich der
Besitzer dieses luxus-objekts nicht
machen im türkischen Bodrum Ankern die
Yachten eines milliardenschweren
russischen Oligarchen der in der EU und
den USA ganz oben auf der Sanktionsliste
steht sein Name Roman Abramovic in
Istanbul saß der enge Vertraute von
Kreml Chef Putin in der ersten Reihe als
der türkische Präsident Erdogan im März
dieses Jahres Ukrainer und Russen zu
Verhandlungen an den Tisch bat die
Gespräche blieben ohne Ergebnis aber
Erdogan setzt weiter auf Annäherung an
Putin er fährt damit aus der Solidarität
im nato-bündnis aus Erdogan den
Sanktionen gegen Russland ab auch weil
die angeschlagene türkische Wirtschaft
auf russisches Gas und Öl angewiesen ist
Erfolg hatte Erdogan mit dem
getreideabkommen dank türkischer
Vermittlung können Weizen und
Sonnenblumenöl aus Odessa wieder auf die
Weltmärkte auch wenn der Export derzeit
schleppend läuft weil Russland
aufwendige schiffskontrollen durchsetzt
am Bosporus stauen sich über 100
beladene Frachter das getreideabkommen
hat die Türkei international gestärkt
für Putin bringt es eine Menge Vorteile
zum einen ist die Türkei sein Tor in die
Welt vorbei an allen Sanktionen zum
anderen ein NATO-Mitglied das ihnen
hofiert für erdogan ist der Schmusekurs
mit dem Kremlherrscher aber ein
Drahtseilakt zwar lassen die Russen hier
die Kassen klingeln bei
Fluggesellschaften oder
Immobilienmaklern zum Beispiel aber sie
verstärken auch die
Ausländerfeindlichkeit angesichts von 5
Millionen zuwandern und Flüchtlingen im
Land im nächsten Jahr wird das ein
Wahlkampfthema und es könnte den
politisch angeschlagenen Erdogan weitere
Stimmen kosten
seid die Regierung in Moskau eine
teilmobilisierung angeordnet hat sind
die Flüge aus Russland nach Istanbul
ausgebucht eine Entspannung ist nicht in
Sicht weder im Krieg in der Ukraine noch
beim Zustrom der Bürger aus Russland
die überwintern lieber am Bosporus oder
am Mittelmeer in sicherer Entfernung von
Putins Kriegsmaschinen
die Türkei ist NATO-Mitglied in dieses
Verteidigungsbündnis wollen zwei
skandinavische Staaten neu hinein in der
Hoffnung auf mehr Schutz vor Russland
das sind Schweden und Finnland wie das
im Einzelnen aussieht zeigt euch
classtomsen im nächsten Beitrag wenn ihr
lust auf noch mehr Videos habt dann
abonniert unseren Kanal